I am really excited about my next guest  but I want to start with the show of  hands how many people here love food  trucks okay so please welcome  first-timers to our show Gabi diamond  and Sofia retreat Mason oh we're gonna  do a group of all that's good oh that's  nice ok Gabi want to use sit here Saphir  why don't you take the end there ladies  honestly this is brilliant but which one  of you got dumped hyatt actually if we  both did we were dating brothers and  they both dumped us on the same day okay  so how do you go from being like double  dumped to selling food off a truck and  did it start with just like okay let's  all put off a truck and serve everything  with a side of he is toast so funny  Rachael Ray but Tony guys what is what  is actually your best seller so far oh  well that that would be the burger um  it's made with arugula and a honey  truffle sauce and it's named after my ex  boyfriend Josh Kaminski it's called the  I can't Kaminski burger  you